[Music]
[Applause]
i'm a gamer so i like to have goals i
like special missions and secret
objectives so here's my special mission
for this talk
i'm going to try to increase the life
span of every single person in this room
by seven and a half minutes
literally you will live seven and a half
minutes longer than you would have
otherwise just because you watched this
talk
okay some of you are looking a little
bit skeptical that's okay because check
it out i have math to prove that it is
possible and it won't make a lot of
sense now i'll explain it all later just
pay attention to the number at the
bottom plus seven point six eight two
four five eight three seven minutes that
will be my gift to you
if i'm successful in my mission now you
have a secret mission too
your mission is to figure out how you
wanna spend your extra seven and a half
minutes and i think you should do
something unusual with them because
these are bonus minutes you weren't
going to have them anyway
now
because i'm a game designer you might be
thinking to yourself
i know what she wants us to do with
those minutes she wants us to spend them
playing games now this is a totally
reasonable assumption given that i have
made quite a habit of encouraging people
to spend more time playing games for
example in my first ted talk i did
propose that we should spend 21 billion
hours a week as a planet playing video
games now 21 billion hours it's a lot of
time it's so much time in fact that the
number one unsolicited comment that i
have heard from people all over the
world since i gave that talk is this
jane games are great and all but on your
deathbed are you really gonna wish you
spent more time playing angry birds
this idea is so pervasive that games are
a waste of time that we will come to
regret that i hear it literally
everywhere i go for example true story
just a few weeks ago this cab driver
upon finding out that a friend and i
were in town for a game developers
conference turned around and said and i
quote
i hate games waste of life imagine
getting to the end of your life and
regretting all that time
now i want to take this problem
seriously i mean i want games to be a
force for good in the world i don't want
gamers to regret the time they spent
playing time that i encouraged them to
spend so i've been thinking about this
question a lot lately
when we're on our death beds
will we regret the time we spent playing
games
now this may surprise you but it turns
out there is actually some scientific
research on this question it's true
hospice workers the people who take care
of us at the end of our lives
recently issued a report
on the most frequently expressed regrets
that people say when they are literally
on their death beds
and that's what i want to share with you
today
the top five regrets
of the dying
number one
i wish i hadn't worked so hard
number two
i wish i'd stayed in touch with my
friends
number three
i wish i had let myself be happier
number four
i wish i'd had the courage to express my
true self
and number five
i wish i'd lived a life true to my
dreams
instead of what others expected of me
now as far as i know no one ever told
one of the hospice workers i wish i'd
spent more time playing video games
but when i hear these top five regrets
of the dying i can't help but hear five
deep human cravings the games actually
help us fulfill for example
i wish i hadn't worked so hard for many
people this means i wish i'd spent more
time with my family with my kids when
they were growing up well we know that
playing games together has tremendous
family benefits a recent study from
brigham young university school of
family life reported that parents who
spend more time playing video games with
their kids have much stronger real-life
relationships with them
i wish i'd stay in touch with my friends
well hundreds of millions of people use
social games like farmville or words
with friends to stay in daily contact
with real-life friends and family
a recent study from michigan university
showed that these games are incredibly
powerful relationship management tools
they help us stay connected with people
in our social network that we would
otherwise grow distant from if we
weren't playing games together
i wish i'd let myself be happier well
here i can't help but think of the
groundbreaking clinical trials recently
conducted at east carolina university
that showed that online games can
outperform pharmaceuticals for treating
clinical anxiety and depression
just 30 minutes of online game play a
day was enough to create dramatic boosts
in mood and long-term increases in
happiness
i wish i'd had the courage to express my
true self well avatars are a way to
express
our true selves our most heroic
idealized version of who we might become
you can see that in this alter-ego
portrait by robbie cooper of a gamer
with his avatar and stanford university
has been doing research for five years
now to document how playing a game with
an idealized avatar changes how we think
and act in real life making us more
courageous more ambitious more committed
to our goals
i wish i'd let a life true to my dreams
and not what others expected of me are
games doing this yet i'm not sure so
i've left a question mark a super mario
question mark we're gonna come back to
this one
but in the meantime
perhaps you're wondering
who is this game designer to be talking
to us about deathbed regrets
and it's true i've
never worked in a hospice i've never
been on my deathbed
but recently i did spend three months in
bed
wanting to die
really wanting to die
let me tell you that story
it started two years ago when i hit my
head and got a concussion now the
concussion didn't heal properly and
after 30 days i was left with symptoms
like nonstop headaches nausea vertigo
memory loss mental fog
my doctor told me that in order to heal
my brain i had to rest it so i had to
avoid everything that triggered my
symptoms for me that meant no reading no
writing no video games no work or email
no running no alcohol no caffeine in
other words and i think you see where
this is going
no reason to live
of course it's meant to be funny but in
all seriousness
suicidal ideation is quite common with
traumatic brain injuries it happens to
one in three and it happened to me
my brain started telling me
jane
you want to die
it said
you're never going to get better
it said the pain will never end
and these voices became so persistent
and so persuasive
that i started to legitimately fear for
my life
which
is the time that i said to myself after
34 days and i will never forget this
moment i said
i am either gonna kill myself or i'm
gonna turn this into a game now why a
game well i knew from researching the
psychology of games for more than a
decade that when we play a game and this
is in the scientific literature we
tackle tough challenges with more
creativity more determination more
optimism and we're more likely to reach
out to others for help and i wanted to
bring these gamer traits to my real life
challenge so i created a role-playing
recovery game called jane the concussion
player now this became my new secret
identity and the first thing i did as a
slayer was call my twin sister i have an
identical twin sister named kelly and
tell her i'm playing a game to heal my
brain and i want you to play with me
this was
an easier way to ask for help
she became my first ally in the game my
husband kiosk joined next and together
we identified and battled the bad guys
now this was anything that could trigger
my symptoms and therefore slow down the
healing process things like bright
lights and crowded spaces we also
collected and activated power-ups this
was anything i could do on even my worst
day to feel just a little bit good just
a little bit productive things like
cuddling my dog for 10 minutes or
getting out of bed and walking around
the block just once now the game was
that simple adopt a secret identity
recruit your allies battle the bad guys
activate the power ups but even with the
game so simple within just a couple days
of starting to play
that fog of depression and anxiety
went away it just vanished it felt like
a miracle now it wasn't a miracle cure
for the headaches or the cognitive
symptoms that lasted for more than a
year and it was the hardest year of my
life by far
but even when i still had the symptoms
even while i was still in pain
i stopped suffering
now what happened next with the game
surprised me i put up some blog posts
and videos online explaining how to play
but not everybody has a concussion
obviously not everyone wants to be the
slayer so i renamed the game super
better and soon i started hearing from
people all over the world who were
adopting their own secret identity
recruiting their own allies and they
were getting super better
facing challenges like cancer and
chronic pain
depression and crohn's disease
even people were playing it for terminal
diagnoses like als
and i could tell from their messages and
their videos that the game was helping
them in the same ways that it helped me
they talked about feeling stronger and
braver
they talked about feeling better
understood by their friends and family
and they even talked about feeling
happier
even though they were in pain
even though they were tackling the
toughest challenge of their lives
now at the time i'm thinking to myself
what is going on here i mean how could a
game so trivial intervene so powerfully
in such serious and in some cases life
and death circumstances i mean if it
hadn't worked for me there's no way i
would have believed it was possible
well it turns out there's some science
here too
some people get stronger and happier
after a traumatic event
and that's what was happening to us the
game was helping us experience what
scientists call post
growth which is not something we usually
hear about we usually hear about
post-traumatic stress disorder but
scientists now know that a traumatic
event doesn't doom us to suffer
indefinitely instead we can use it as a
springboard to unleash our best
qualities and lead happier lives here
are the top five things that people with
post-traumatic growth say
my priorities have changed i'm not
afraid to do what makes me happy
i feel closer to my friends and family
i understand myself better i know who i
really am now
i have a new sense of meaning and
purpose in my life
i'm better able to focus on my goals and
dreams now does this sound familiar it
should because the top five traits of
post-traumatic growth are essentially
the direct opposite of the top five
regrets of the dying now this is
interesting right it seems that somehow
a traumatic event can unlock our ability
to lead a life with fewer regrets but
how does it work how do you get from
trauma to growth or better yet is there
a way to get all the benefits of
post-traumatic growth without the trauma
without having to hit your head in the
first place that would be good right i
uh i wanted to understand the phenomenon
better so i devoured the scientific
literature and here's what i learned
there are four kinds of strengths or
resilience that contribute to
post-traumatic growth and there are
scientifically validated activities that
you can do every day to build up these
four kinds of resilience and you don't
need a trauma to do it now i could tell
you what these four types of strength
are but i'd rather you experience them
firsthand i'd rather we all start
building them up together right now so
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
play a quick game together this is where
you earn those seven and a half minutes
of bonus life that i promised you
earlier all you have to do is
successfully complete the first four
super better quests and i feel like you
can do it i have i have confidence in
you so everybody ready this is your
first quest here we go
pick one stand up and take three steps
or make your hands into fists raise them
over your head as high as you can for
five seconds go
all right i like the people doing both
you are overachievers very good
well done everyone now that is worth
plus one physical resilience which means
that your body can withstand more stress
and heal itself faster now we know from
the research that the number one thing
you can do to boost your physical
resilience is to not sit still that's
all it takes every single second that
you are not sitting still you are
actively improving
the health of your heart your lungs and
brains
everybody ready for your next quest
i want you to snap your fingers exactly
50 times or count backwards from 100 by
7 like this 193 go
don't give up
don't let the people counting down from
100 interfere with your counting to 50.
nice
wow
that's the first time i've ever seen
that bonus physical resilience well done
everyone
now that's worth plus one mental
resilience which means you have more
mental focus more discipline
determination and willpower we know from
the scientific research that will power
actually works like a muscle it gets
stronger the more you exercise it so
tackling a tiny challenge without giving
up even one as absurd as snapping your
fingers exactly 50 times or counting
backwards from 100 by seven is actually
a scientifically validated way to boost
your willpower so good job quest number
three pick one now because of the room
we're in fates really determined this
for you but here are the two options if
you're inside find a window and look out
of it if you're outside find a window
and look in
or do a quick youtube or google image
search for baby your favorite animal now
you could do this on your phones or you
can just shout out some baby animals i'm
going to find some and put them on the
screen for us so what do we want to see
sloth giraffe elephant
snake okay let's see what we got
baby dolphin
and baby llamas everybody look
gotha
okay one more baby elephant
feel we're clapping for that that's
amazing
all right now what we're just feeling
there is plus one emotional resilience
which means you have the ability to
provoke powerful positive emotions like
curiosity or love which we feel when we
look at baby animals when you need the
most and here's a secret from the
scientific literature for you if you can
manage to experience three positive
emotions for every one negative emotion
over the course of an hour a day a week
you dramatically improve your health and
your ability to successfully tackle any
problem you're facing this is called the
three to one positive emotion ratio it's
my favorite super better trick so keep
it up
all right pick one last quest shake
someone's hand for six seconds or send
someone a quick thank you by text email
facebook or twitter go
looking good
nice nice
keep it up
i love it all right everybody that is
plus one social resilience which means
you actually
get more strength from your friends your
neighbors your family your community now
a great way to boost social resilience
is gratitude touch is even better here's
one more secret for you shaking
someone's hand for six seconds
dramatically raises the level of
oxytocin in your bloodstream now that's
the trust hormone that means that all of
you who just shook hands are
biochemically primed to like and want to
help each other this will linger during
the break so take advantage of the
networking opportunities
okay well you have successfully
completed your four quests so let's see
if i successfully completed my mission
to give you seven and a half minutes of
bonus life and here's where i get to
share one more little bit of science
with you it turns out that people who
regularly boost these four types of
resilience
physical mental emotional and social
live 10 years longer than everyone else
so this is true if you are regularly
achieving the three to one positive
emotion ratio if you are never sitting
still for more than an hour at a time if
you are reaching out to one person you
care about every single day if you are
tackling tiny goals to boost your
willpower you will live 10 years longer
than everyone else and here's where that
map i showed you earlier comes in so the
average life expectancy in the us and
the uk is 78.1 years but we know for
more than a thousand peer-reviewed
scientific studies that you can add 10
years of life to that by boosting your
four types of resilience so every single
year that you are boosting your four
types of resilience you're actually
earning 0.128 more years of life or 46
more days of life or 67 298 more minutes
of life which means every single day you
are earning 184 minutes of life for
every single hour that you are boosting
your four types of resilience like we
just did together you are earning
7.68245 837 more minutes of life
congratulations those seven and a half
minutes are all yours you totally earn
them
wow
wait wait wait
you still have your special mission your
secret mission how are you gonna spend
these seven and a half minutes of bonus
life well here's my suggestion these
seven and a half bonus minutes are kind
of like genie's wishes you can use your
first wish to wish for a million more
wishes pretty clever right so if you
spend
these seven and a half minutes today
doing something that makes you happy or
that gets you physically active or put
you in touch with someone you care about
or even just tackling a tiny challenge
you are going to boost your resilience
so you're going to earn more minutes and
the good news is you can keep going like
that every hour of the day every day of
your life all the way to your deathbed
which will now be 10 years later than it
would have otherwise
and when you get there more than likely
you will not have any of those top five
regrets because you will have built up
the strength and resilience to lead a
life truer to your dreams
and with 10 extra years you might even
have enough time to play a few more
games
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you